right so it's this time of year again
it's the end of the year Q&A you
probably know the drill you've asked me
questions I'm going to answer them I'm
feeling very sick at the moment so I
apologize if I sound a bit off but so
the first question has been asked by
roughly everyone and so it's is terminal
history coming back and I'll expand on
this by saying why I got rid of it so I
got rid of it for probably the reason
you can imagine it was YouTube's de
monetization policies so what was
happening is in January of this year for
the first time I released one Episode a
week and two of them got demonetised
which means during that month I lost
literally half of my revenue as such I
decided to then split the episodes into
two and start doing two separate topics
a week the reason being that when
inevitably I did get to monetize I would
only do say one-eighth of my income a
month it was basically a case of India
if January had continued I'd have lost
the ability to mate to do this for a
living
teman history is obviously a lot of fun
I miss going into that much depth but
ultimately if things were to monetize
then they would be for completely
arbitrary reasons then I can't make a
living and so obviously that needed to
be done I do miss it honestly but I have
no plans to bring it back at the moment
I would like to and ultimately I reckon
my last ever video on this channel will
be a 10-minute history one but Never Say
Never any period you won't cover because
of how confusing it is not really
because things are confusing but simply
because they're complicated and I don't
feel I'm able to explain them most
topics I can wrap my head around pretty
easily it's just a case of there being
certain areas where I know so little
about I don't have any framework with
which to work from for example say
medieval India what is your favorite
period in history
so my answer always used to be 16th
century European history it was mostly
the Reformation and they later Counter
Reformation that I really liked since
then that answer has changed now my
interest is largely late 19th early 20th
century political history because I mean
obviously it's very interesting I also
think it's now becoming evermore
relevant and also it's got Bismarck so
obviously and to counter this least
favorite period of history it's not so
much as they're a period of history I
don't like it's just periods that I
don't know very much about gun to my
head I'd have to say pre-columbian South
America because I have no idea what's
going on and thus I can't like it
Koenigsberg or Kaliningrad I mean
obviously Konigsberg who we sure
favorite historical figure and why it
largely changes depending on who I'm
reading about at the time a consistent
one that I've always liked is Theodore
Roosevelt though
are there any historical events you were
never discuss for any reason yes but I
can't tell you because that would
constitute discussing them what's the
hardest thing with presenting history on
YouTube so there are two difficulties
the first one is actually condensing
information I mean often I'll takes on
30 40 page sort of jstor articles and
then condense them into a three minute
video which isn't exactly easy the
second thing is it turns out when you
write a sentence it doesn't necessarily
sound good spoken aloud and sometimes
you end up writing tongue-twisters do
you know or wish to learn any languages
other than English so no I don't speak
any other languages unless you count
sort of being forced to learn Latin like
so many other English children are but
barring that now I have very basic
German but I've been told my
pronunciation is atrocious although to
be fair I pronounce English words pretty
terribly too thoughts on paradox grand
strategy games I think they've been
responsible for a couple of leyte videos
top 5 Germany's 5 the Vimal Republic for
the Holy Roman Empire three current
Germany to East Germany and one
obviously the Kaiser Reich what country
do you feel doesn't get nearly as much
attention as it should in the history
books so I'd probably say Poland in fact
I definitely say Poland and also the
rest of Eastern Europe because it turns
out they existed and also they were very
important what inspired you to use that
draw style so I can't draw and paint had
a rounded rectangle tool favourites a
baton song at the moment it's Lawrence
of Arabia which by the way the video it
turns out indy neidell is in that which
is pretty cool can you recall what got
you into history in the first place so
actually what got me into history was
civilization 5 so there's a scenario in
that game the fall of Rome in which you
can play either the eastern half at the
Roman Empire or the western half and I
had no idea that the Roman Empire was
split and then I went down the rabbit
hole and I've never come back up what
are your opinions on channels like time
ghosts being demonetised and I'll expand
on this by saying where I feel the
history on YouTube is that at the moment
and where I think it's going if that's
what interests you so in terms of time
ghost
I think that it's ridiculous that
they're consistently being demonetised
at this point it seems strange to me
nothing even remotely nothing on that
channel strikes me as being even
remotely controversial and so I think
it's weird I understand that advertisers
are very cautious about stuff like this
for example you don't want to say hey
drink this delicious drink
back to the Holocaust but ultimately it
seems weird to say to educational
content you can't make money off of this
platform they'll just have to find the
information somewhere else and so yeah I
think it's pretty ridiculous that
they're being demonetised as for where
my opinions are on history in YouTube in
general I think it's in a very weird
place and that 2020 is going to be quite
a difficult year for some channels if I
had to put my opinions out there I'd say
that within the next 12 months you're
probably going to see a few history
channel's buckle and probably stop
making content I think that YouTube's
heading in one direction in which
educational youtubers are going to be
placed into the not trusted category and
the trusted category I don't know where
I'm gonna be I'm not worried about where
my channel is going or anything I'm
pretty comfortable at the moment but in
terms of these other channels you see
that they upload videos and they just
immediately demonetized and I think that
once you get to monetize a certain
amount it sort of starts this snowball
effect and you really you'll struggle to
get out of it as such I can see some
channels just simply never getting to
monetized and I think within the next
order of six or twelve months you're
gonna see them making many many many
more patreon appeals if those don't work
those channels are alternately going to
stop as the people who run them are
gonna have to get different jobs yes so
this is a really unhappy ending to the
Q&A but that's my feelings on on where
YouTube is at the moment I don't think I
don't think it's gonna be great for many
people I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching but thanks to
my patreon supporters whom you can see
on screen now plus with an extra special
thanks to Danny Maloney cool and
Castleman party boy Co Rob Waterhouse Mo
Aaron the white Michael Reynolds Chris
wicker Gustav Swan
James Bissonnette Ashwin Emperor Gareth
Turner David Silverman spinning three
plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check a
Spencer Lightfoot Winston k-word Anthony
Beckett Kelly moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn Skye Chappell
and Ike